Let's, let's contrast and compare a little bit here. What I find interesting is
that there's the game industry where we we see that a lot, because the games
out there. and there's sort of computer aided design, which is sort of a
different kind of a graphics, different kind of a 3D computer graphics way of
doing things. So, well for starters, what, what, what would you say is the
biggest difference between sort of games programming and computer-aided design
programming?
&gt;&gt; I think the end result is, is the big difference. In that, if you were playing
a game and something happened with the visuals, you know, a frame or two goes
off. The worse that happens is your avatar dies.
&gt;&gt; If you mess up in a computer aided design package, people can die. It's[LAUGH],
it's just that there's, there's much more, I think I have much more invested
in, in Autocad, because of the importance of the work that it does.
&gt;&gt; Well with game design, it's, it's kind of a a limited field, in a sense, in
that, they're in total control over the product, and there's a whole team
working on that.
&gt;&gt; Your product is different in the sense that you're selling it to people and
they're using it for who knows what. Can you tell us some of the differences
there?
&gt;&gt; Well, like I say, in games, the world and the behavior is fairly static. The
things happen and things can move around and change, but in general, like I
said, there's a lot of control that The, the game designers and the game
programmers have over what's going on in the game. Whereas with the CAD system,
our users can do pretty much anything. And an interesting this is that CAD
systems, you can view it as a way of creating content. So people can actually
write games using a CAD system to design the assests for the game And then play
the game. So, they can, they can almost interact with each other that way. But
you need a lot more flexibility within, your, the CAD package or what, whatever
package you're using to design the assets for the game. Once you get into the
game they're a lot of tricks that programmers play and artists in order to, to
fake things out and for, get whatever you need done. Again, you can also deal
with the fact that if you're a little bit off one frame, it won't hap, won't
really matter because the action is moving quickly enough that you'll get right
past it.
&gt;&gt; Right. I mean, just the fact that there's a reality to, you know, whatever
you're, whatever you're building, makes sense that there's, you know, Autocad
and so on. It really has sort of different kinds of constraints. well with
that, for example, I mean
&gt;&gt; Are their constraints as far as precision or elements like that.
&gt;&gt; Well, definitely we, we have to deal with things like, we have this one model
that we use internally for a lot of testing which is the model of the solar
system. So we have to have auto cad be able to go all the way from the, looking
at the entire solar system down to looking at a plaque on the moon that was
left by Neil Armstrong.
&gt;&gt; [LAUGH]
&gt;&gt; And we need to be able to read the lettering on that plaque. So just the range
of precision that we have to deal with can, can really blow away a lot of the
graphics hardware, so again, there're some tricks that you have to play in
order to be able to handle the all that different resolution with only single
precision floating point.
&gt;&gt; Can't break it.
&gt;&gt; The nice thing is, that we're dealing with soft, we had our software
implementation. Of course we had double precision, we could deal with it much
better but, when you, when your end result really requires single precision.
That's where it gets tricky.